oh I just wish it was like 911 911 in
comparison to this was so nice
it was so first of all it was the fall
it was the fall and you know the
holidays were coming and yes you felt
unsafe and yes your friends died died
and yes you went to a lot of candlelit
vigils but you could be together
you could hug each other kiss people on
the cheek you could sit in a bar the
booze was flowing and the food and you
could go out and be together there was
humanity there were displays of
compassion all around I just wish it was
like 9/11 in the fall eating pumpkin
muffins talking about other bombs we
were gonna drop on the evil towers it
was such a nice time it was so simple
there were evil people who had done an
act of unspeakable cruelty and there
were good boys and girls in Long Island
New York who were going to go to school
and try to figure this world out because
we were young and we had promise when
this [ __ ] happens when you're 35 and you
realize you're [ __ ]
you were almost [ __ ] before the
pandemic it's not fun a crisis is not
fun in your mid-thirties it's okay when
you're 17 because you have so much to
learn it's okay
you're 17 II like I'm becoming a person
this is a formative period in my life I
mean it's like at this point I'm
oscillating between friends you think
the virus is fake and friends who
desperately want to get the virus
because they want Instagram followers
they want attention I got two types of
people calling me people telling me the
virus doesn't exist and I'm falling for
propaganda and people that think they
have the virus and want to just tell
people to have the virus because they
need [ __ ] attention they're praying
for Corona these are the two groups of
people I have in my life in their
mid-30s just waiting for the guillotine
to drop
I just wish it was like 911 was so nice
and simple and I was so young I didn't
understand anything about the world and
I started reading Thomas Friedman who
wrote for the New York Times and he
doesn't understand anything about the
world but I thought he did cuz I was 17
and he would write stupid things like
the world is gone from interconnected to
hyper-connected and I would go [ __ ] I'm
smart I get it and then you grow the
[ __ ] up and you realize that nobody has
any clue what's going on and life is
truly a waste of time the articles are a
waste of time the tweet threads are a
waste of time
it is truly all just something to do
there's no way to contextualize anything
nothing makes [ __ ] sense throw open
the doors to the church if that's where
you find yourself and I don't blame you
whatever you got to do if you find
yourself in an anarchist vegan compound
and [ __ ] Portland because you're a
communist witch and that's the only way
you can stay sane God love ya no
judgement from me I've given out right
and wrong Republican Democrat left and
right it's all disgusting we're all just
germs waiting to go a buy back
statistics are stupid people are
genuinely insane and I don't mean fun
insane I mean no genuinely rubber room
danger to themselves and others insane
and you share a country with them and
they have a vote in you ever vote and I
don't know how that works I don't
understand how that all works long term
and the people with the money and the
power of taking the last train out and
they've shut the lights off and they've
grabbed everything they can and they
took the last flight out and left you
standing on the tarmac and you went and
what did you think they wouldn't you
thought you were getting any of that two
trillion dollars good luck baby you're
getting 600 or 1200 depending on what
fake tax bracket you're in and it's all
fine we're in the end of winter the
worst time the beginning of spring March
is the worst month and it always has
been the worst month because you you you
you understand how bad February is gonna
be it's gonna be cold it'll suck it
feels like forever and then you get to
marching of all this false hope and then
March is just a rainy allergy filled
hellscape where if everybody didn't have
Corona they'd think F Corona because
everybody wakes up with a sniffle or a
cough or post-nasal drip because it is
[ __ ] March the worst month in the
world you're just sick you're sick of it
and you need the Sun and the heat and
the summer you know you need that that
time when you could just you know take a
little breath take a little breath step
away go to your beach club go to someone
else's beach club go find a friend with
a boat go trade up go find a friend with
a little more going on than you have so
you can enjoy this summer you can't
enjoy the summer unless you make friends
with a little bit of money let's get
real the summer is not for the poor it
ain't never husband I know you saw some
movie about somebody swimming in a creek
that ain't real anymore that's not real
the quickest thick the creek is sewage
now so if you don't have a friend with a
beach house you're [ __ ] you're in a
public pool where people are [ __ ]
and they're bleeding from their aids
legions not me buddy oh I'm gonna make a
friend with a big boom nice big pool and
a plump cheeseburger I put my fat face
and I'll sing and dance for it
I'll sing and dance and I'll make all
the funny and
I make all the anecdotes they want I'll
make all the anecdotes they want as long
as I can visit their pool or their Beach
because that's that's really what the
summer is you got a trade up in the
summer get the forget the losers away in
the Sun I don't care how you made your
money I don't care if you sold masks to
nurses outside of the ER I want that
pool I don't care I don't care how much
blood money it took to get this house in
the Hamptons I'm not going to a public
pool or god forbid a beach club the
refuge of the middle class no cops and
firefighters for me this summer get out
of here no Italians and Irish Jews and
wasps I don't give a [ __ ] about this
pant [ __ ] Demick if I'm alive I'm
gonna get a rich [ __ ] friend for the
summer you better take a look at your
social circle and think of all you
[ __ ] who's gonna be laughed at who's
gonna have a little coin I've been
trying to donate to coronavirus and it
is very difficult and I'll tell you why
they don't need money as much as they
need supplies they need masks they need
ventilators I cannot make a ventilator
in my West Hollywood apartment I lack
the skill I lack the material I don't
know what it is I could I make masks I
don't know but I don't think I can and
the masks that I make would just be
insulting it would be stupid so
anticipating that this is a larger
economic problem of course it impacts
lots of people I guess somebody told me
today they said you could just donate to
a food bank and all right but guys guys
guys how sexy is donating to a food bank
let's get real does anybody want to
donate anonymously to a food bank I want
to donate to something where I can can
show the world that I'm doing it so I
can inspire them
I want a photo of me outside
cedars-sinai I want two doctors and a
nurse crouched on the floor holding
their stethoscopes and I want to be
behind them with my hand on each of
their backs and I want that photo I
don't need to go anonymously donate to a
food bank I want some big something
glossy a little sexy sexy I know they're
going through with doctors and nurses I
that I know that and it's [ __ ] sucks
out there and I want to help them but I
also want to be photographed doing it
but if that makes me a bad person
fine if that make if you don't want to
listen to the show anymore or then fine
I want to be photographed helping I'm
not saying any of the documentary about
me helping that wouldn't be horrible
either but I want to still photograph or
a few of them of me helping in whatever
capacity I help I want that's all so if
there's a way for me to help that is a
little sexy please let me know a little
bit of a photo op I appreciate all the
first responders and nurses and doctors
taking time away from patients to send
me messages on Instagram so I know
what's going on for my show I appreciate
that
don't stop keep sending those messages
just keep sending them doesn't matter
what the hell's going on in there keep
me abreast of all the local developments
on the ground please it's another
pandemic all my relatives are going to
somehow survive great 9/11 the financial
crisis every kind of cancer they're
unbeatable these people the boomers or
you can't get him can't get him they're
gonna they're gonna walk around like
Lazarus raised from the dead complaining
about the temperature of shrimp why
it's wrong as if did you leave it out
for too long I'm telling you you're not
gonna beat the boom buddy people think
this is this virus the boomer remover
think not
it'll get some people and that's [ __ ]
tragic but the boomers are gonna be back
and they're gonna be back with a
vengeance this is their Holocaust they
are good there will be you think the
boomers were bad before they are gonna
talk about covert 19 the way people talk
about Krystal mock I'm telling you
they're not gonna let it go you'd think
they were annoying before these
[ __ ] are gonna go hard they're
gonna go hard they'll Stella nurse right
to her face that she doesn't know [ __ ]
they'll be like well you don't even
where were you I was a nurse on the
front line the front lines are what yeah
young I was old in my house having to be
racist in my home and not at the local
restaurant they're not going anywhere
folks the Bloomie's are not going
anywhere I'm reading a lot of things
where they're saying that the 2.2
million expected death total you know it
is a little high they might be revising
that down but they also think you know
obviously day to day it's a [ __ ]
nightmare and I have a lot of [ __ ]
people that listen to the show that are
out there in the trenches and I [ __ ]
respect you guys and I appreciate it and
I wish I could help you but I can't
legally can't leave the house so I will
send a tweet I will do a story on
Instagram and I will even maybe do a
tick-tock dance but I can't leave the
home and but I will donate money or I
will do something I want to order you
guys food I want to do something for you
I'm providing a lot of entertainment
let's be honest let's get real here
there's not a lot of shows doing it like
we're doing it right now they're
actually funny it's a lot of garbage
there's a lot of collaborate people on
zoom' and everything and you can't hear
anything
first of all enough with the guests
enough with the guests if you need get
stopped broadcast give us your opinion
you don't need to save 30 comedians
interview each other over and over again
until the planet explodes have a thought
and articulate it you're asking people
that
you money how about that yeah how'd you
get in the comedy will you take a bow
yeah shut up n times you goon enough
with the guests no I don't want to
collaborate I don't want to collaborate
with you and a pandemic I'm gonna
collaborate in a pandemic know everybody
retreat to your corners do your own
thing you're gonna have a lot of
pandemic friendships people gonna call
you that you never speak to and they're
gonna and you're gonna like my friends
with this person you might be but it's a
pandemic friendship there's gonna be
pandemic relationships you're gonna
start [ __ ] somebody that's near you
because it's a pandemic you know I tend
to believe that relationships aren't the
most valuable when they only make
themselves known during a period of
absolute and utter desperation and
crisis you know what I mean I tend to
think in order to find out who your real
friends are free associations needed the
ability to leave your home those small
benefits of being able to walk down the
street and meet other people and stand
closer than six feet away from them so
just be a little careful be a little
careful with the pandemic collaborations
the disease friendships you're making
just we get it don't be upset when they
lift the travel restrictions and that
person travels the [ __ ] out of your life
that's all
don't don't don't be don't be afraid to
look at things with you know your head
right now as well as your heart what are
the totals we do this every episode we
do this not to be crass and not to you
know but to just figure out where we are
this is Thursday this episode is going
to a Saturday night early Sunday morning
I guess everything could change in a day
or two but this is the most recent
totals we have of sick cases we do the
world
and then we do the United States of
America and I am [ __ ] bummed that New
Orleans is having a time of it down
there cuz other than New York it is my
favorite city and I love it
we have a total of five hundred thirty
two thousand two hundred twenty four
cases in the world and a total of twenty
might wait a minute.what 530 2224 okay
this one right yeah and then deaths we
have twenty four thousand eighty seven
for the US right now we are at eighty
five thousand five hundred ninety four
cases total deaths thirteen hundred okay
cuz you hear the numbers here's the
thing with this you hear the numbers and
you go everything's about what could
happen and what might happen because if
you look at the numbers and you're like
why do we have a morgue if there's only
been a certain amount of deaths you know
like why do we have a like a frozen
morgue ready to go why are we converting
you know what why can't we handle
because more people die than this we're
about thirteen hundred but I think it's
the expectation that this thing gets so
brutal so ugly and so many people end up
dying that like Italy you're not going
to be able to to have funerals and it is
[ __ ] deeply tragic that that [ __ ]
could be happening because I get it guys
I'm getting frustrated with the social
distancing I'm getting very frustrated I
want to [ __ ] leave my apartment I
mean I do I walk around and stuff but
like I'm I've had enough
dude I I've spent the last decade doing
stand-up comedy and I spent the last
decade traveling traveling all over the
place to a point where the majority of
my day when I wasn't traveling was just
complaining about travel yeah as to how
horrible it is to travel dang my life
coughs and colds and shove and dayquil
down my throat and Advil cold and sinus
and sniffles and you know the plane and
everything the germs and that was my
entire [ __ ] existence and now I'm
locked locked down locked down I'm only
able to pod
and then you fall into the internet you
fall into the black hole the abyss you
know I liked performing I liked people
after shows coming up to me shaking my
hand to go and hey that was great or ham
a big fan you see the human face of
people it you lose that when you're when
you're inside and you're online you lose
that you lose that there's [ __ ] real
people out there that connect with what
you're doing I appreciate all the
messages and [ __ ] you guys send online
you know but it's so I'm just it's I'm
just I'm so envious of the nurses and
the doctors that get to leave their
house every day they're so lucky
I hope they realize how lucky they are I
hope they truly appreciate how lucky
they are the nurses and the doctors and
the first responders they get to just
gallivant wherever the [ __ ] they want
I'm just I just hope they realize what a
unique position they're in that's all
that's all I'm saying and listen let's
talk about the economy for a minute I
don't want to sound heartless I don't
want to sound heartless but let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
is it inappropriate to ask that somebody
on a ventilator work is it inappropriate
for me to suggest there were jobs you
can do while you're on a ventilator is
it wrong I'm dead serious why not if
you're intubated and you have tubes and
your machine is breathing for you
I'm your medically induced coma is there
nothing you can do I mean I don't know
I'm not an expert but I know the economy
is paramount and everyone's concern hmm
you know Domino striked of course I'm
kidding for you idiots out there they're
probably he's right he's right about
what about it hey what guy should be
Walker wha-what do they go pump
chick-fil-a Wow after all this is done
and after the nurses wore the garbage
bags and after everybody dies there's
people gonna be like babes
at Lee Greenwood song it's gonna be so
far I'm proud to be an American where at
least I know I'm free
[Music]
great ah but that's the thing the
economy Trump says we're gonna have the
church is full by Easter Nicole if the
app is a quote the Easter Massacre
started killing everybody on Easter you
know doctors say that this thing is
[ __ ] unpredictable in every
imaginable way you don't know how it
really affects you
you'd be healthy and drop dead you can
be unhealthy and it could be okay you
can be old it could be young it doesn't
you know they don't know anything about
it they don't truly have a real
understanding of this it's it's all
pretty much based on averages and
numbers and Chinese full of [ __ ] I mean
something so Rogan sent me an article
the other night which I don't know if
it's making the rounds Ben's gonna pull
it up where it says China's missing 21
million Utah cell phone users they just
went offline hmm yeah it was in
Bloomberg if you know anything about
China you know that their cell phones
are way to track the population so you
know cell phone is pretty important in
that country especially of that
government they want you to have a phone
they want you to have a phone so they
could find out what the [ __ ] you're up
to so China mobile subscriptions fell by
more than eight million over January and
February data on the company's website
show China Unicom Hong Kong subscribers
fell by seven point eight million in
this period well china telecom corp has
lost 5.6 million users last month what
are we saying does this mean that the
death totals are much higher and that
they're running 24-hour crematoriums and
they are just burning bodies I don't
know I'm asking a question I'm saying
does this mean that the death total is
so much higher so much heart now they're
like Spain has more deaths in China it's
like wait what that's what they're
saying look it up does it make any
[ __ ] sense
or maybe not more deaths but more cases
what are they saying
um so on the worldö meter we have a
t-1000 in China and 57,000 in Spain
that's oh but des yeah by like two
thousand more yeah 1,500 more no way
dude I call bluff yes no way China's but
China's Juke in those number China I
know what you did you you're good you
China is taking people and throwing them
in a furnace by the way you know where
their cases went out cuz if you go
report a case they go oh thanks hold on
you know when you go into a doctor and
they sit you on the little thing and
they go they take your blood pressure go
hold on the doctors gonna come in it and
being in a minute if you complain of
kovat symptoms they to Chinese guy goes
yeah hold on a doctor be in a minute
and then the military comes in to shoot
you in the face I mean there's no way I
mean like if you're reporting those
symptoms right now they are not even
listening they're not hearing that ain't
nobody got time for that they're gonna
put the gun in your throat yeah they're
gonna pretend this is some thermometers
you're gonna look at it it's gonna be a
gun they're done
China's done with this [ __ ] they're like
we're done with coronavirus next they
don't give a [ __ ]
hey guys gotta be honest with you it may
be it's not the worst attitude I don't
know I don't know I flippity-flop I'm on
the fence here you know we cannot we
cannot sit in our homes for six months I
know some people think we can save no
idea the economy works and they're
masturbating all day they think this is
fun they're eating pancakes and just
whacking it and they're like this is
great what's everyone's problem some of
us like to get out and do something does
it mean do it tomorrow we're not going
there but I'm saying eventually we need
to kind of we need to get out we you
know we can't just have [ __ ] we can't
all be sitting here waiting for martial
law forever mm-hmm you know looking out
the windows going wonder the tanks gonna
roll down the street we don't want a
bird in the hospitals I get it you know
but you still have to keep your eye on
the prize
think event you know when things are
good in the summer you can eat some
baked clams and you know what's great
about this country if the death toll is
not as bad you know you're just gonna be
out to dinner or some other people to
look or fork or told you I'll told you
it was food so it's like almost like
what's more annoying going out to dinner
with those people or just let's take a
million or two people in or two and
let's get and get them out of here yeah
cuz those people are gonna be so
annoying that even though I don't want
two million people to die those people
at dinner are gonna be so [ __ ] brutal
to sit down and listen to cuz they're
gonna be like you know yeah real big
plague that was she almost wanted you
know what I mean right right
you almost want some stats of course we
you know you don't want anyone that we
know to die right let's keep it
strangers or people I don't really love
a lot of people that haven't done enough
for me the business let's be honest my
level of talent does not correspond at
all to my level of money I should have a
lot of [ __ ] money and I don't I have
enough don't worry I've enough we're
doing fine we're getting by the patreon
but like look look at the but I will I
could introduce you to millionaires who
I mean these people I mean they can't
spell their name I'd be truly eighty
thousand cases in the u.s. eighty five
thousand cases yeah what is New York
have right now New York leading the pack
n why see thirty seven thousand cases
three hundred eighty seven deaths in the
state of New York you know it's
interesting man it's a real reset for
anybody who's young if you're under 25
it's time to move back home if you can
move back home listen don't don't be
upset don't think it's a failure but if
you if it's at all possible for you to
go back home for 12 to 24 months and
save [ __ ] money
there's
no shame in it this is a reset I can't
go home
my mother's in a mental institution and
my father and his wife lived together
I can't there is no home for me to go
and I'm 35 that's all so you can't go
home when you're 35 that's it you're in
your mid-30s you the home you go in
you're 35 is your death eventually
you're closer to that than the age when
you can just walk you know go home
which is why in retrospect what a great
time
9/11 was it was just such a fun [ __ ]
time 9/11 Wow just growing up being
young you know is it gonna be anthrax
it's gonna be smallpox what's gonna get
us bioterror nothing happened there were
no additional attacks you know you know
what's great about 9/11 everything made
me a hero going out and getting drunk
maybe a hero because if you didn't go
out and get drunk the terrace one right
oh so good if you didn't go out and get
drunk and eat a sandwich at 2:00 a.m.
the terrorists one do you want the
terrorists to win no so you go live your
life remember President Bush he said
what can americans do he said go
shopping go shopping because that's what
we are we got to lean in a little bit to
that we are demons from hell that's
really what we are we're not a good
country of good people that idea has to
be smashed let's lean in its I get it
when Bush is like go shopping he's not
wrong
he's like what are you guys gonna do
anyway what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do to grief counseling shut
the [ __ ] were you gonna what are you
gonna volunteer your time to talk to
people do grief counseling no go and buy
a dress go get a car and drive it real
fast fatty go get a panini press go get
a waffle iron I mean that's what we do
we shop or the terrorists win we get
draw
or the terrorists win that was a great
thing about 9/11 you were it was your
patriotic duty to consume to consume to
go out and gorge yourself with food and
wine and booze do shots with your
friends and get [ __ ] up on the
weekends because this is America and
that's how we roll and Al sama bin Laden
will never take that away from us he'll
never take away our ability to go out to
bars and get [ __ ] up with money that
we stole from our parents one way or the
other sometimes it was hard stealing
there's a little money on a mantle it's
mine sometimes you go right into the
pocketbook right into the purse take a
little bit off the top go right in there
and grab a couple of 20s 50 oh we got a
hundred gotta be a good night gotta be a
good night hope she doesn't notice she's
out of you a lot of people in Long
Island stole klepto maniacs they steal
money I love it I would take money every
now and then I was a junk box druggie
some people did it sober that's funny to
me
hilarious I mean I know people were
stone-cold sober stealing from their
families great no excuse stealing
stealing clothes you know something very
deeply wrong with the area that I come
from it's a sickness worse than Corona
it's worse than kovat it's a hundred
percent rate of being a piece of [ __ ]
that's the statistic you go up in Long
Island yeah full of malls you get a job
because your mother's friend Deb know
someone at the Rec Center you just sit
there in a chair and watch people almost
drown in the pool life is a meaningless
waste of time
don't kid yourself and don't kid
yourself I don't think much will change
in this country to this upend I mean I
thought that it would or my people are
gonna start getting serious they'll move
out to the suburbs are gonna want kids
you can wanna go awry you know they want
real
I don't know I don't know it would be
great if that [ __ ] ends if your [ __ ]
one-man show is over if you realize that
you want to get you know something real
in your life tangible property family
you're not just gonna waltz around being
a dilettante pretending to be an artist
wasting your own time and everybody
else's you know your could get dangerous
again the economy could get bad moving
to a city like that could be a real risk
the fun might be over you better really
[ __ ] want it you better really want
it if you gave you could get a knife to
your throat on the a train you better
really want to be [ __ ] funny and
interesting you better really want
otherwise the pull of the traditional
life the life that many of you should be
living the traditional life that it's
gonna be it's gonna be very strong after
this pandemic my prediction could be
wrong is that the pull of that tradition
is gonna come back suburbs back I want
space I want property I want a house how
many people are quarantine in a box
right now going no more I want out
I want I want something real I want to
love someone I want them to love me I
want real responsibilities I don't want
to host affair with her friends and
people trying to step on my neck to get
ahead I want to get the [ __ ] out of
these cities like New York and LA and go
people like me are gonna stay but we
should stay because we're we're good at
what we do you ain't and you know I'm
talking to if you're sitting out there
and you listen to this and you're like
you're gonna be yeah yeah yeah if you
even think like that I'm talking to you
you should be sitting there gonna [ __ ]
this fat [ __ ] I'd do it better than him
and then you got a shot if you're
sitting there god [ __ ] this guy I could
do that show better is what his Netflix
is whatever everybody sweats this guy
but [ __ ] him who cares
I would do it better oh I'm Megan McGann
good that now I respect you you little
demon but you'll still fail
cuz life's a [ __ ] so don't get too high
on your high horse
okay I just booked a Luis Gomez for an
hour this is what happens I forget how
much I like Luis you need people like
Luis right now you're gonna need people
to figure out ways because there's gonna
be a lot of naysayers and doom stares
I'm one of them I'm gonna tell you to
jump off a building
Luis is gonna give you a ladder and the
ladder is gonna break and you're still
gonna die but it's gonna feel nicer see
what I mean guys you've watched your
show you not bad my skin is a little kid
I've Irish skin you know which you know
Irish is great if you're Irish you can
you know tell fun stories and you have a
you know predilection for alcoholism
you're you know maybe in the arts you're
a fun hang you know Irish people are
great they don't cook they don't know
how to really do anything with money but
they are they're fun you know maybe you
might own a bar you're the life of the
party but your skin is grotesque I know
this from myself it's red its scaly it's
blotchy I always envied my Italian
friends had a little more melanin you
know but my skin was just always a
problem you know no matter how I looked
at my life periods of losing weight
gaining weight whatever it is your skin
just looks like [ __ ] it just does if
you're if you have fair skin you know
many people have different kinds of skin
it's not only Irish people but I'm
speaking for myself I know that you know
I have that blotchy kind of Irish
translucent skin that all of my emotions
just bubble up in me and you could see
them on my face little dots of red and
you know what I started using is
something called Hawthorne okay and
Hawthorne has a lot of different stuff
they have a cleanser deodorant shampoo
body wash lotion all of these things
made without the chemicals are you're
gonna find in places you know when
you're when you're getting stuff in a
drugstore okay they have really
something cool I like Cologne I was
never a cologne guy but I do like
Cologne
and Hawthorne will definitely help you
elevate your scent with an entire line
of personalized colognes that's kind of
cool
smelling good is important Hawthorne
smells really good and they make the
process of finding and buying your
signature scent easy you take a quiz at
Hawthorne it takes about two minutes and
it tells you exactly which products
match your style in order to come up
with the perfect kid for you they'll ask
you the usual questions about your skin
type how often you wash your hair and
they'll tell your products to where you
work and what you do for fun so the
climate I mean this is an interesting
place because the climate of where you
live you know what your skin is like
what you do for a living are you outside
you inside they'll they'll tailor all of
the products to you personally and
there's none of the gross chemicals you
get in the store-bought stuff and they
offer personalized skin care cleanser
and lotion tailored to your specific
needs so if I say to Hawthorne hey hi
horn I'm a gay drug addict but I've been
sober for ten years I haven't declared
bankrupcy but I bought a house it was
foreclosed on I live in the underground
economy in and out of apartments my
mother's a schizophrenic and I have fair
skin help
they will tailor something to me I don't
know what they'll do I might send a
Bangor cocaine out with the cleaner but
give them the information you'll take a
quiz I'll ask you questions you know all
the other stuff whether it's Cetaphil or
surive a whatever like that's one size
fits all they pump billions and billions
of gallons of good glop into something
and you know they have no idea who you
are you have no personal relationship
Hawthorne which is what I like it I was
able to take the quiz it was super easy
I said this is what I do this is my skin
problems been mine and I've been using
it I just started using it I'm gonna
tell you next week how good it is but it
feels better my skin feels lighter it
feels better it feels more hydrated and
moisturized I I was very grateful that
they sent me all that stuff so check out
Hawthorne Hawthorne dot Co Hawthorne dot
C oh okay that's Hawthorne with an e at
the end and use my promo code t IM to
get 10% off your first purchase
10% off the first purchase that's H a w
th o r and e dot co I'm use my code T I
M so if you if you need skin care it's
great way to support the show we're all
quarantine we're all home we all need to
look and smell good deodorant lotions
shampoos all of it all-natural no
chemicals alter you Hawthorne co t IM is
the promo code 10 percent of your
purchase you'll be glad you did
I'm just I'm just ready for this summer
I'm ready for the quarantine to end I'm
ready for these Col you know you gotta
call your family now hi hello yeah
that's better
I know it's bad I know oh you're not
going out either I'm not going out yeah
I know I know
no one's going out yeah yeah yeah no and
your family split between people who
were like Trump's a hero or Trump's the
Antichrist and you know whatever maybe
maybe maybe maybe it's gonna be
interesting Easter Easter for me was
never a holiday that I loved I mean it
was you don't get anything it's not like
Christmas it's not good food I mean he
ster is about honey baked ham what it's
about now my nanny made a great mustard
and vinegar glazed ham which is even
better
she took vinegar and Gulden's yellow
mustard I mean which is just a beast
mode on that pink ham beast mode
you own the appropriate potatoes on
Easter or au gratin there oak gratin you
[ __ ] Savage mashed potatoes fine but
it's an au gratin potatoes oliday it's a
pink ham holiday or a lamb holiday it is
not or beef you can do a Chateaubriand
you could do porterhouse you don't do
fish Christ's came back you cheap [ __ ]
you don't do fish you do a [ __ ] roast
if you're Hispanic you can get away with
fresh pork and [ __ ] I'm not telling you
lonna live last thing I need is a nice
to my [ __ ] throat it's not pasta god
help you
it's not pasta it's not a casserole it
is steak ham or [ __ ] lamb nice
rosemary crust on that lamb nice garlic
and herb Oh gratin potatoes string beans
the desserts are no chocolate this is
the rule chocolate is for the the
baskets the desserts are pastry creams
and fruit okay that's what it's about
light desserts appetizers on there
nothing the dips all the other holidays
you can have some warm appetizers
Eastern's inappropriate you have salads
like tips things like that it's it's a
feast holiday it's it's about a roast
and the dessert shouldn't be heavy
chocolate winter desserts we're in
spring now okay you do you know like a
you know it's a great Easter dessert is
that milk rape cake veal mill what are
from New York City we're just layered
with crepes and cream very that's a
perfect [ __ ] desert on Easter you
piece of [ __ ] oh the podcasting oh look
at you like this yeah I like that I
don't I don't want to look at you the
[ __ ] over it yeah I'm gonna have to look
at you you get what I'm saying
okay enough go watch something else why
don't you look at the camera why doesn't
your studio look like an adult tree
house why not why don't you read
listener mail I don't cuz I don't care
what you say read listener mail why
don't I listen to your show you listener
mail you [ __ ] on crack can we send
him questions no we did a live stream
you asked the question that's sending it
a question
um but that's what Easter is about it's
a good holiday
if you eat and you you know but you
gotta eat don't don't [ __ ] around you
know do the right thing there you know
you're not gonna be able to have Easter
now you're gonna have what your end
here's the other thing let me say
another thing about you quarantine
content stop with the cute families
doing like choreographed dances there
are people wearing garbage bags
contracting this disease and dying stop
with your choreographed family pajama
dance you psychopath what in God's name
is wrong with you I'm glad it took a
pandemic for you to be a parent I'm glad
but keep it to yourself there are people
that are struggling and dying they can't
breathe on their own nobody needs to see
you in a choreographed dance with your
family and pajamas like it's a big
[ __ ] snow day it ain't a snow day
maybe this is why we maybe I'm a little
loud this is why they're complaining
it's a [ __ ] I'll get out of this
apartment in three [ __ ] months I'll
go to some warehouse
think I give a [ __ ] this [ __ ] all think
I'm impressed here you [ __ ] apartment
dwelling pigs [ __ ] own houses huh
scumbags I love this complex you Google
everybody's father he was paying the
[ __ ] rent degenerates he's [ __ ]
apartment complexes West Hollywood they
charge a lot of [ __ ] money because
everybody's everybody's a loser and they
can't get a house but there they think
you're less of a loser than some
Kentucky person who eats carnival food
because they get to live in Hollywood
[ __ ] you you're a pig
and I'll kick in your face I'll beat
that property manager out I will fight a
woman
I will fight a middle-aged woman in the
streets hummus at Easter you serve
something like that cuz it's MIT the
themes Middle Eastern I'll grab a hair
I've seen a woman get her hair yank like
that she's not expecting it yeah oh yeah
should have thought better of that yeah
only if she hits me first and I'm
protecting myself the point that I'm
trying to make is this stop treating
this like a big snow day it's not a
vacation for the people that are in the
hospital right now working their asses
off you know like all kidding aside
these people are [ __ ] working their
asses off you know and I just think it's
a little what you know there was this
one with his one tick tock where you
know people send me tic TOCs I'm not
even on the [ __ ] I should get on it
people send me tick tock there's just
one family that's like it's my mom's
birthday so world dressing up tonight to
feel special even though we're in
quarantine come again you're you're in
quarantine because there's a disease
ravaging people's life we're all
dressing up tonight to feel special in
quarantine you are special you dumb [ __ ]
you're not sick and you're not [ __ ]
helping anyone in the hospital
you're the most privileged person in the
world right now because you're [ __ ]
not sick and you ain't broke and you got
enough [ __ ] money to eat so shut the
[ __ ] up you wanted to feel special by
putting a [ __ ] dress on
you're as special as you get you
heartless [ __ ] sounds like I'm always
against women but there's men also [ __ ]
doesn't is not gendered to me her father
was there an account level brother my
cousin said that he's like that would
never happen in our family like here we
hate each other my family hates each
other and it's my favorite thing about
them it's true my family we you know we
really dislike each other but we're open
about we're honest about it we'll tell
you right to our face go yeah we don't
not for me how's your Uncle Joe yeah not
for me but it's just like let's [ __ ]
calm it the [ __ ] down with how happy we
are under you know it's like a big snow
day it's a snow day look at my look at
my new socks that match my pajamas I'm
eating french toast in bed outside
there's just gunshots and screaming you
just hear dogs screaming howling at the
night
people I want to feel special you're
lucky a quarantine with a few not many
people are alone right now man I'm alone
right I mean Ben comes over and I have
all of you [ __ ] rejects that [ __ ]
listen but you know how many people are
alone right now like old people that are
[ __ ] alone and terrified and you're
on [ __ ] tik-tok dancing just just
[ __ ] understand that you're lucky
there's a lot of people that are alone
right now man
mentally ill people that are very sad
you know you know some of them said the
pandemics not worse but many people can
go either way I'm just sick of sitting
in this apartment I'm sick of the
[ __ ] you know two of the rooms and
you have carpets it dry my allergies
[ __ ] crazy you know I'm taking a
[ __ ] thermometer every day make sure
I don't have kovin go the corona virus
stop thinking Andrew Cuomo is gonna be
your savior he's a meatball he's a
goddamn meatball he is better than Joe
Biden I mean Joe Biden is I mean Joe
Biden cannot be nominated to run for
president he is shot he cannot be
nominee he has dementia you got to go
with Bernie Sanders or Andrew Cuomo and
I hate Cuomo because he's a meatball you
know he didn't shut down the city quick
enough and then he reversed his decision
and then everyone praised him for it
like he's making the tough choices yeah
make it a week before make it a week
earlier save people's lives I don't like
him I don't like his brother Chris at
CNN I do not like them the Irish and the
Italians have destroyed the country okay
they've destroyed it with their thuggery
so I don't want president meatball I
don't need that garlic not why is he on
TV every day why do you have a press
conference every day you're not the
president you'd think he was running for
president he's on every single day hey
your dog New York is a problem but like
we're doing every
do we care what dude I talked to my
friend Sal at the pizzeria and he sent
us a calzone to the hospital so
everybody could eat hey it's Andrew
Cuomo my brother works at CNN his name
is Chris my name is Andrew I'm a garlic
knot I'm a sausage and pepper hero on
the governor of New York and everybody
likes me cuz I can speak I can literally
enunciate a word that's what he's so
good like that's lit that's how bad it's
gotten in the country where people like
he's a good speaker he's not a good
speaker he can talk that's the level
we're at he can speak he's able to talk
Joe Biden's like well you know you know
the UH declaration Exedra so many peas
literally coming in and out of it do his
aides know I bet they know about Symone
Sanders knows that big black chick that
[ __ ] wasn't it great to see her take
that white animal rights act to his
contrite off the stage love that but I
bet Simone knows and she's like we're
just gonna run you were running Joe and
that's it that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna run [ __ ] Biden and you
know yeah he's [ __ ] his brains rotted
you know I mean why not it's a
dysfunctional Society why not have the
head of it have dementia you know it's
you know it's like a failed state here
we can't get masks to nurses do you know
how many frozen yogurt shops we have in
this country I love somebody you know
there's a great article in the Atlantic
about what could happen after the pin
that meets very hopeful it's a guy being
like people are gonna turn to science
and kids are gonna they're not gonna
want to be celebrities gonna want to be
scientists and public health is gonna be
the main issue in every political
campaign and I was like man man I hope
you all right but man I beg to differ
god I beg to differ
I'll tell you that much
kids are gonna want to be scientists
yeah okay we'll see they're licking
toilets which kids the ones that are
licking toilets and coughing on the
fruit those kids are gonna be scientists
yeah doesn't I don't think they've
internalized this I don't think they've
really realized this yeah who knows that
could be wrong I talked for so much
today it's like my third hour of podcast
made it's amazing how much just raw
talking you're approaching like four
hours of podcasting today it's crazy
yeah and then I gotta shoot this dumb
thing for David Spade show god I mean
I'm really had it I was wanting to bed
on the couch earlier I'm like I can't do
it anymore
that's not right I I just like to go
places you know I like to get on a plane
get the [ __ ] out of Dodge I like to go
to Dallas I like to go to Austin I like
to go to Vegas those are my three
favorite cities at the moment to go to
Austin Dallas in Vegas they're all
somewhat close Texas not really you know
dude what's [ __ ] Vegas gonna do Vegas
is very weird I have a love/hate with
fake it's because you know I've been to
Vegas a bunch and I've had some of the
best times in my life in Vegas but I've
had some rough times too in the sense
that like I went there with a girl in
senior year of high school that she was
into me and I was you know [ __ ] I had
to ruin it by being a [ __ ] it's like
you know I mean I didn't ruin it
immediately but I mean eventually it was
ruined so Vegas is always kind of like
this weird town of like comp like to me
I'm like oh you gotta kind of know
there's the thing about Vegas where it
brings you face to face with who you are
and what you're willing to do right it's
like what what are you willing to do how
much you willing to gamble who are you
willing to [ __ ] who are you willing to
lie to you what are you willing to do
what version of yourself can you be can
be any version in Vegas it's very
interesting town Vegas and I've always
even when I went there the last time and
we had dinner with ty Rivera a funny
comic we were there I was like in love
with the restaurant we were at and
repulsed at the exact
same time yeah and I was like I love
this that we're watching a show outside
while we're eating and I hate it and I
love it and I hate yeah and that was a
whole ask my feel about face a lot of
it's a lot of people feel the same way
about New York when I talk to people
about New York that lived there for a
few years it didn't grow you know they
don't have like roots there or whatever
they're like oh man I love it and I hate
it I just but Vegas is interesting
because it just it it there's this
endless amount of options about you know
what you can do or do you have money are
you pretending to have money are you
there to have a threesome are you there
to [ __ ] hook up are you did a gamble
are you there to see a show are you
gonna perform you there to be but I also
like the freaks in Vegas I like tonight
you know the freaks of the night the
people that are at the people used to
inhabit cities like New York you know
you know before you know all those
freaks started hedge funds
I like that element of Vegas you know
you go down alike I think it's Fremont
Street I mean it was you know we were
walking down there I was like I mean it
was rough yeah down there you know that
big praying mantis shooting fire out of
its antennas yeah [ __ ] weird yeah
yeah you know I mean it's I was gonna
say it wasn't primitive so I was gonna
say and then it was a neighborhood comic
and it's gonna make you laugh so hard
over but I week or so funny like that
wasn't permanent that was blank
yeah nothing so funny but then I thought
quickly and I was like who can I say
where they won't be mad and everyone's a
continent no one so we have to abandon
that joke
and that won't hit ever as hard because
it's not but that's one of the best
jokes that I deal with Ben is he'll say
something other than that that was blank
it's kind of like a quick little Woody
Allen one one-liner um we're gonna see a
homeless person walking by and you'll
you'll be like hey you know blank right
he just did Conan or whatever correct
yeah it's a good reoccurring jokes it's
never not funny it's never not brightens
today and the worse they look the
funnier it is yeah like if it's some guy
just no shoe on wandering around
with his own [ __ ] in his hand holding
[ __ ] and I go hey you know this guy it's
funny but Vegas is gonna get hit Vegas
gonna get hit it's gonna get hit but
Vegas will always find a way you know
Vegas is a tough place and the people
that live there are tough people and a
little crazy and that's kind of what you
need in a downturn you need people to be
tough and a little crazy and people that
live there and people that you know they
tolerate risk in Vegas that's what the
whole [ __ ] town is the whole thing
and I think that city even though it's
because it was crushed in the financial
crisis 2008 came back was crushed you
know so it's a it's a city that I find
pretty interesting and I and I'm
wondering how rough the road back is but
the road back is gonna be rough for a
lot of places cuz we're not even not
even in the problem God right
you know everybody on TV is like we're
not even in the thing yet I'm like what
when's the thing
when's that can we not have press
conferences until that right cuz I can't
take a month lead up to that I thought
we were in it we're not even here we're
not even in the thing well we're not
even in the wave the wave hasn't Crested
what what's happening I mean can we can
we get to that can we get to that now is
your way to rush that can we get to the
wave week off on some all people do a
shock test the system what do you want
to do here but that becomes
dredge report is saying desk will top
80,000 in the next four months did you
see that yeah here's here's with my
question okay
yeah that's horrible um what is that
what is that based on the amount of
people they think will get it verse the
more top you know saying it may not
subside until June according to a data
analysis done by University of
Washington School of Medicine I think
these data analysis models are not doing
anybody any good I think they're
important to share internally with
hospitals but why do we keep putting
this [ __ ] out in the news if it's based
on like what the [ __ ] you know put a few
of them out let people know if they
could be settling in for a long haul why
do we need a new model everyday that's
based on you know just projections yeah
we don't know this could have been
circulating for three months we you know
people have no idea you know I mean
looking at the new data analysis model
this will crest in 2000 2028 it's like
what it's not useful this is not useful
information these wild projections I'm
not useful information tell people what
to do
now tell people what they can do now
we're looking at April May June I'm
telling you right now folks we cannot
have a 90 day quarantine I don't think
we can I just mean for the cut and I'm
not saying like I don't want to put the
vulnerable people out to work nobody
should die for this I'm not saying any
of that but I'm wondering if we can have
a 90 to 120 day quarantine can we have
shut the economy down for 90 to 120 days
I don't I don't know I don't think so
that's six or twelve hundred dollars
you're getting is not going to do
anything for ninety or I mean 120 days
so I think what eventually has to happen
is once we get a handle on this we have
to start opening things up in inland
small doses there's just not a other
options here you know if we could all
sit in a bubble for a year and somehow
eradicate all of it I just don't think
that's gonna happen I think it's gonna
be you know a few months but I think may
towards June we're gonna be looking at
you know hopefully and then we're all
gonna be so [ __ ] traumatized when
they open the doors and go you're
allowed out we're gonna go no yeah you
know we're gonna go no you're
institutionalized yeah yeah yeah I'll
stay in my cage thank you
maybe that's what they want I don't know
I'm not I'm not I'm not for that which
is why I've always been critical of the
people that are like this isn't real the
virus isn't real because I'm not an
idiot
so I talk to people and they go oh it's
real yeah on the other side though I'm
very aware of how this can be used to
enslave a population of people I'm not
an idiot
I know that when you take away
everybody's rights and you suspend
rights that they would normally have had
for an indefinite period of time
you're dramatically changing the way
that they live and that at the end of
that it can be incredibly tough to you
know just to the idea that that power
isn't just innate in the government they
shouldn't be able to do shut it down and
tell you absent - pandemic absent a
public health crisis and then what is a
public health crisis clearly is one but
what down the road could be one that
will be turned into a public health
crisis what you know down the road can
be used to shut it down
I you know these are questions these are
real questions you have to ask yourself
you know you're getting a ticket for
jogging in certain cities so these are
real you know you know this ain't
Oh drill this is the reality of where
you are and you have to understand that
while you're sacrificing your freedoms
temporarily you cannot indefinitely
surrender them and you can't you know
you can't also think that that's not a
possibility or that there are people
that don't want you to have those four
you don't want you have any freedom
truly a lot of people do not want you to
have any freedom and people will
voluntarily give up much of their
freedom without guns without you know
I'm looking a lot of cities and you know
the expectation is a crime will go up I
probably will certainly well but I also
think that you're gonna see a situation
where there's so much publicizing of
that fact oh we're not gonna prosecute
small petty crimes and the petty crimes
like actual crimes cars getting stolen
burglary so real crimes property crime
is a real crime but when people start
publicizing that they're not gonna do
anything about that I'm like what does
this do other than terrorize the public
what are we doing here other than
terrorizing the public and I think that
what purpose does that serve other than
terror keeping it terrified so I think
that we have to just you know it's a
[ __ ] hard cuz you gotta you know it's
like a gymnastics you got to stick the
landing you don't fall either way you
know not that I'm a gymnast but you know
when I used to watch the Summer Olympics
stick the landing you got to stick the
landing here in terms of like you can't
be like the virus is fake you also can't
be like hey just let me know I'm just
gonna make waffles in my PJs and not
[ __ ] grasp what is happening which is
the shutdown of the largest economy in
the world and they like a pandemic you
know like you you have to understand
what is happening here you have to you
have to kind of process that and you got
a compartment
because you can't go out do the wrong
thing and violate these orders and be
unethical put other people at risk and
at the same time you can't forget that
there isn't outside and there is a job
you have to return to and that everybody
has to return to and you're not gonna
Radek ate every case of coronavirus
before that happens does it mean we're
all gonna be you know [ __ ] in churches
and Easter you know but at the end of
the day you gotta you gotta say to
yourself hey you know this eventually
ends this eventually comes to a close
and then we look back at it we saw how
unprepared we were and we try to figure
out a way to be more prepared you know
but I mean this could easily turn into a
situation where this lockdown that comes
you know a problem a big problem more of
a problem than the pandemic and the
government uses this to take the few
remaining rights away that you have and
I don't you know I don't like that
that's why the ubi idea I was like it's
a great idea if I trusted the government
but since I don't the idea that you
could just keep people universal basic
income and just say sit in your house
stay in your house here's your money
you don't go earn money here's your
money uh it's scary scary the idea that
government could just pay you to sit
there you know I mean there's something
about that that should trouble you
because now the only way you eat is
government you know my friend said the
other day like he's trying to apply for
an employment young guy and he goes yeah
unemployment man the system's crashing
they won't answer my calls I'm like yeah
welcome welcome to welcome to what its
gonna be welcome to what its gonna be
when you don't and he's frantic he's
like I gotta get through I gotta get his
money I was like welcome to what its
gonna be when he can't earn a living
when the one thing that's been taken
from you and now you are dependent
on you know the government to earn
living I'm not saying the government
can't do certain things I'm not saying
they can't you know provide a level of
health care to people basic health care
so that people aren't going bankrupt
every other day but I I don't want and I
have no business this is why I'm not a
Marxist and I don't a lot of that you
know some of the Sanders platform I
agree with but a lot of his fans are out
of control I don't want the government
providing me every need in my life I
don't want that then they get to decide
what my needs are I don't want that I
don't want that because that is how you
slip into you know whether it's fascist
or communist there's not too much of a
[ __ ] difference
truly I mean I know people rip me up for
that but it's true in terms of
authoritarian structures what they are I
don't want I want the ability to earn a
living I want the ability to choose
where I live I want the ability to
choose who I go into business with I
want to choose the industry that I work
in I want to choose how much money I
save I want to choose all these things
and if I'm unable to do that and I
prevented from doing that I am now I've
become some type of slave or bought
whatever you want to say maybe that's
the updated version of that whatever it
is I don't have any power and I have no
interest in that and that is a
totalitarian society and you see it see
it in China you see it in a lot of
places you see in North Korea and if you
think it cannot happen here you're
insane
it'll be a different kind of
totalitarianism it'll be soft it'll come
with the Kardashians
you know it'll come with new there'll be
new TV shows everywhere here Jimmy
Fallon and have you met Jimmy's wife and
it's it'll be a soft totalitarianism it
won't be hard it won't be the cane and
Singapore will be a soft atala Terran
isn't where you're just fed garbage on
television you're fed garbage you you
know you consume garbage whether you're
eating it or listening to it or watching
it and you don't have any power and you
don't have the ability to go out they've
already broke in like the labor movement
if you're a worker in this country have
very little power just don't have that
little you don't worry
of power if you're any type of
independent journalist you have very
little power you have almost no other
than utilizing the Internet but you have
no mainstream power you can't get your
articles no matter how well research
they are and well sourced you can't get
them in front of people you know you can
you can go indie and put them online and
things like that but you're boxed out of
the mainstream there's four or five
companies that disseminate all the
[ __ ] information they own all the
channels they own all the radio stations
it's [ __ ] four or five conglomerates
and they just strangle that industry so
if you're an independent journalist you
just don't really have you don't have
the opportunity you just don't you know
you've been boxed out the big money and
the the consolidation of those major
companies those conglomerates has
eliminated your ability to really truly
break through you know people say that
about YouTube about everything it's
harder now to a massive following it's
harder to make money because the
conglomerates the cartels the groups of
people have come in and they've carved
up a lot of these things for themselves
Google Facebook know there's five
companies if you want to do anything
online you've got to be you know Google
Facebook Amazon YouTube there's there's
a few platforms that you have to be in
business with there is no other way you
know so the type of fascism that will
arrive in America it's not gonna be like
the boot to the face
fascism it'll be like yeah checkpoints
yeah you just can't go here this is you
got to get approved to fly somewhere and
it could be done all under the guise of
public health
it could be done yeah where you going on
vacate well we'll tell you we'll let you
know we'll let you know if you're
approved to go on that trip we'll let
you know if you're approved to drive
down this street we'll let you know if
you're approved to to live in this
community because we have decided what
car you can buy because we've decided
this is bad for the environment you can
you can buy this car we're still gonna
have the other car we're gonna have the
guns in the big cars and everything but
you're not and and we're gonna still
have the houses with the gates behind
them but
you know we'll decide where you live
we'll decide what industries you can be
and will regulate you out of them will
tax you out of them will prevent you
from getting into them well we'll just
we'll cut you off we'll cut you off the
knees so the idea that all of this
cannot be turned on you and and truly
used to so and that doesn't mean that
you run out tomorrow and you're coughed
on your grandmother's throat and you it
doesn't mean that it means that you pay
the font pay attention be vigilant
don't don't be stupid don't be making
not tick tock videos in your underwear
understand what's [ __ ] happening to
this country it could go bad quick could
get bad quick your leaders okay are in a
precarious position and who knows what
the [ __ ] they'll do god only knows what
these people do if their backs to the
wall you got to realize there's a lot of
people that aren't a fan of what has
been happening whether it's Epstein
whether it's some type of awakening
there's a lot of people that have a lot
of money in the old structures in the
old system and they don't like that you
can get on the internet which is slowing
down by the way I love reading those
articles the Internet's slowing down
everyone's on it getting real slow maybe
well maybe you can't use it on Tuesday
maybe your day will be Wednesday I mean
think all of these things aren't pot
they're all possible trust me and
they're just a lot of people out there
that don't love how the Internet's been
used to unmask a lot of what they've
been up to they're not fans of that so
if they could if they could eliminate
that they would now they can't yet but
watch them just me and watch these
people like a hawk to be honest with you
and I mean that doesn't mean that this
isn't a real disease and it isn't a
crisis and the social distancing isn't
justified because you know after 9/11 a
lot of the things you were very that
they implemented made a lot of sense in
that moment they made so much sense in
that fever
[ __ ] of rhetoric when we were all
terrified when like what the [ __ ] and
then they passed all of these things out
we're gonna read your email and we'll
read your email and listen your phone
and you know track you everywhere and
imprison you if we want to when they
torture you for information and we don't
have to charge you with anything well
suspend habeas corpus and you're not
gonna be read your rights and we're not
gonna officially bring you and if we
want we could just put you in a military
tribunal show court and you don't get
any type of democratic you know you
don't get any type of trial and there's
no democratic process you know we just
just everything the country's based on
we're gonna take away we're gonna take
that away now everything that the
country has been based on we're gonna
we're gonna get rid of that we were we
weren't right about that we were wrong
about that sorry our bad my bad so just
don't forget that that could happen here
and you know this is a weird thing
because it's this invisible enemy that
we're gonna be fighting you know
wouldn't it be funny if like terrorism
you know after after a while if like we
just came don't care anymore like 9/11
like when people start talking about
terrorists and muzzles we don't even
care whether we don't stop like stop
it's 20 years ago nothing's happened
since he you can't get I said well like
says no you don't care would it be funny
if in years just so you know talking
about this don't like what about
coronavirus like you shut the [ __ ] out
we know you [ __ ] we know we don't
have coronavirus again enough you know
is that what the government's gonna be
able to all they had to do was mention
an Arab guys name and the whole country
was like you know turned it a little
Hitler's high standard like it's all
they're gonna have to do now just be
like this they're just gonna have to go
uh hey everybody and you go [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's right go inside go inside take
cover
it's corroding yeah I had a me tied up
just before I go I had a yeah it's very
interesting ma'am
you don't know you'd really don't know
what where life is gonna end up life is
surreal it's [ __ ] insane
I mean there's there's I mean I you know
there's nothing
me and Ben we're doing this show before
the pandemic we were doing a show in a
bunker before there was a bunker it's
crazy and we were doing a you know we
were figuring out how to exist online
before we had to and we're grateful I'm
grateful for that and for Ben was a huge
part of that um but I will say it's not
a it's not I'm not existing online
primarily is not a nice place to be
sunshine is nice people are nice going
out performing live is nice being
outside and meeting people is nice and
this you know we're gonna be here for
you
we're gonna be here every week multiple
times a week but I'm just saying don't
give up every right immediately think
about this think about where we're going
figure it out because I don't I don't
want to be in a digital world forever
you know I don't want to be it's the
same we're seeing the same thing where
it's like a bunch of people just sat and
watch TV during the 90s was great TV you
know people just sat in a couch potato
look there's a couch potato just sit on
his couch I'm telling you man is not a
nice place to be
Twitter is not a good place to live man
Instagram is not a good place to live
your soul interactions can't be Twitter
fights and just people dancing on
tick-tock or some drunk they find in a
Waffle House parking lot ranting about
something you can't it can't be the only
thing you got it you gotta get some air
Ben made a great point he goes what the
[ __ ] Instagram gonna be if nobody can
go outside right what are they gonna do
people post pictures that were [ __ ]
every day what are you gonna do there's
nothing
to do so my thing here is just it isn't
it a healthy place to live your phone
everyone is living in their phone now it
is not a healthy place it's almost like
the synchronicities they're trying to
bring it about quicker they're like
let's just lock them in their homes
give them their phones and see what
happens yeah let's see if when we let
them out if they want to be let out or
they just gonna be shaking in the corner
with their phone because that's their
only life right that's their only life
source you know that's what I worry
about this is gonna take a toll on
people psychologically it's gonna be
traumatic
you know Timbaland comedy calm who cares
there's nothing there to go and buy
merch if you want get a shirt Tim Jay
Dylan di llo n on Instagram and Twitter
the two things I just told you not to go
to go and follow me the rules are the
rules I am looking for volunteer
opportunities if you're a first
responder and you're low on money DM me
I'll help you if you're legit if you're
legit a first responder like and you're
[ __ ] like you know I don't have a ton
of money but if you're totally [ __ ]
and you're a first responder for
whatever and you shouldn't be [ __ ] you
should have money if you're a first
responder but you know we are gonna find
some some ways and there's I think we're
gonna order food for Hospital that's
coming up soon which is cool so I would
do want to do something you feel
powerless not doing anything but they
need masks and ventilators and what the
[ __ ] do I know you know so you know I
just want the opportunity to kind of be
photographed helping people it's it's so
important that I'm able to help people
you know in public in a verifiable way
it's very public I'm able to go hey I
want at the end of this I want I want to
walk into Cedars and I want everyone to
start clapping
and crying and I want them to go you're
the hero
I go no no you're the hero and then they
hand me like maybe a gold stethoscope or
something that's kind of nice you know
like a plaque yeah and they say thank
you and the mayor of Los Angeles gives
me a key to the city you know yeah you
know and then they look at me and they
go can we tell you something
problems keep a secret and I go yeah and
they go the whole virus was fake like
you [ __ ] guys